DOWN THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE.
>> READY TO GO
HIS NEW YEARS RESOLUTION, QUICK
STARTS FOR T T
>> FOUR SECONDS LEFT IN THE
POWER PLAY.Y BEAR
WORKS IT TO THE NEUTRAL ZONE
TURNOVER.
>> I WAS TALKING ABOUT A COUPLE
CLIPS HIM ON THE KNEES.
THE FLYERS HAVE BEEN FORCINGTKIY
FAST IN THIS SITUATION.
WE SAW LAST GAME WHE
IAFALLO THE FLYERS HAVE BEEN
MAKING IT
PERFECT ENCAPSULATION OFE ALREA.
OFF THE FACE-OFF.
TAKES A LITTLE EFFORT JUST TO
KINGS USING THAT AGAIN, STAMPE.
KEMPE.
GRUNDSTROM CLEARS THE ZONE.
STRENGTH THERE.
WE GET
LOOKING FOR WIN
YANDLE FOR THE POINT.
SWALLOWED UP. GAME.
THE KINGS ARE WELL ON THEIR WAY.
>> FROMM SECONDS.FIRST OPPORTUN.
THEY WIN THE THERE IN
NEUTRAL ICE.
THE KINGS UNABLE TO ADVANCE IT
CLEANLY.
GETTING THE
IT'S ALSO THAT LONG STRETCH PASS
TYPE OF T FROM THE HIGH SLOT.
>> HERE.